scp-682 vs d-3654  could a d-class with an equally  pessimistic and misanthropic world view  as scp-682 make the perfect pacifying  playmate the foundation decided to send  in the most hateful d-class they could  find to have a chat with scp-682  strangely 682 never tried to kill this  d-class they instead just chatted for a  few minutes about their incredibly low  opinions on humanity while researchers  listened from the sidelines turns out  that 682's takes were too spicy for even  d 3654 and after a few minutes of  listening to 682 ranting he slipped into  a catatonic state and died the  researchers who were listening in also  needed to be treated for severe violent  depression